what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and
let's get started
um also before I forget don't forget to
sign up to our Google form to be
notified when we do events and meetups
okay guys
um today we are going to be reacting to
a sandman clip again that is a mgtow
channel and for those of you that don't
don't know mgtow stands for men going
their own way um there's different
levels to mgtow from what I understand
it's there's some guys that just don't
interact with women there's some guys
that only do casual relationships but
don't look for anything long-term and
there's some guys
um that I'm trying to remember it's like
they don't interact they don't oh and
there's some guys that just avoid
marriage like they refuse to get married
but they'll still have a relationship
with a girl so there's different levels
and it sounds
average person right but when you when
you see the systems and the laws that
are signed up to that are in place to
actively discriminate against men I
really do understand where they're
coming from I'm like if I was in their
shoes I don't know how I would react
um but today we're talking about the
vanishing American woman so I'm really
excited to see what his thoughts are
roll the clip hi everyone same in here
this video is brought to you by a
donation from Doug and he says thank you
for everything and I hope you find
Christ but the truth is the truth is the
truth unquote well doc thanks for the
donation since you left it at that I
wanted to cover an article called The
Vanishing American man by Elizabeth
Grace Matthew but I would argue that the
reason men are checking out of soy
Society is because women checked out
first because they stopped acting and
looking like women in Matthew's article
I think about that when I walk down the
street I like count the number of women
in dresses that's true she mentions how
former Nebraska Senator Ben Sasse had
kids that came into his bedroom on a
cool summer night complaining that they
couldn't sleep because the air
conditioning wasn't working that's when
Ben realized he didn't teach his kids
the difference between something being
nice to have versus something you need
to have Ben wrote a book called The
Vanishing American adult in 2017 but
Elizabeth doesn't agree with Ben and she
thinks it's more about the vanishing
American man instead where have we heard
this before of course right and this is
kind of the concept that I had to learn
because I I think there's more
traditional men than there are
traditional women and as much as like
the Trad cons will tell that there there
is a growing number of men that are lazy
and don't want to do anything but the
question is why why are they like this
it's because men typically have been
motivated by a wife and a family but now
what what do they get in return the
average age of first marriage in the UK
is 31 so they get a 31 year old that can
maybe give them a kid or two
um you know body counts are way higher
nowadays so she's not pure she's not
Young and typically we're not overly
feminine so you know you can get mad and
say but the men but like ladies let's
just look in the mirror you know
um as a group I think there's more
traditional men than there are
traditional women but the problem is
that traditional men don't want to deal
with us because we don't have the things
to offer that are grandmothers and our
great grandmothers did and a lot of
times the the Trad cons or whatever will
come back and say well tell the men to
be more and that's exactly what like a
lot of red pill channels do like fresh
and fit or um
other like men's self-improvement
channels but the issue
that you're gonna have it's like even if
a guy's in the top like 30 percent of
men a lot of times he won he has no
guarantee she won't leave and take the
kids he has no guarantee that even a
more traditional woman is brainwashed by
the modern mindset and like there's no
guarantees for him so I can't really
blame them for walking away it's
honestly logical if maybe we didn't have
the systems in place today that we have
um I could see it but the systems like
honestly actively discriminate against
men especially in court because men only
get access to their kids 10 percent of
the time while the good men gone comes
to mind so she says the young women are
going to college at rates higher than
men and now we're earning young men in
some cities but just because men are
staying put in their mother's basement
while women go off to work on their
careers doesn't mean that women aren't
Vanishing too femininity poor etiquette
and slenderness are all being replaced
by morbid obesity bitchiness and a more
masculine appearance the women are still
there technically but it's just the guy
aren't going to work themselves to death
for a 35 year old 250 pound root female
manager working at The Sizzler it's
shocking to some women that many men do
actually have standards she also says
that one of the young women's strengths
is that they're less likely to live with
their parents that simply means that
many men aren't willing to move out in
the early to mid-20s and pay rent money
that they'll never get back women
typically move out from home because
they're most likely to argue with their
mothers women are Vanishing from
traditional appearing Womanhood and yes
men are disappearing from higher
education participating Less in the job
market and if you are looking for
romantic relationships that's because
the juice is no longer worth the squeeze
women just haven't figured that out yet
because their life is more than economic
calculation it's a social calculation
too men are avoiding College which
leaves them unemployable with two
hundred thousand dollars in debt is not
in their best interests increasingly
many men are working for a wage that
doesn't keep up with inflation while
they Dodge me two allegations at work
which also isn't worth it so record
number of guys are checking out of the
labor pool men checking out of
relationships is partially because women
don't want to date down and also because
the quality of the ogres with ovaries
out there keeps on going down by 2030 60
percent of American women will be obese
for a man the bigger a woman gets the
less we notice her ironically she
becomes invisible as a long-term
relationship Prospect the bigger she
gets the less you see her the Brookings
Institute scholar Richard Reeves
believes that one of the reasons the
young men are struggling so much is a
lack of male role models in their lives
others including Missouri Senator Josh
Hawley contend that young yeah but why
do they have a lack of male role models
in their lives because when women take
the children which they do 90 like women
divorce men okay more than men divorce
women so women divorced 70 to 80 percent
of the time so the women are the ones
leaving if we're college educated 90
chance will leave so we leave we take
half of it and we take the kid and now
the kid maybe if he's lucky gets to see
his kid every other weekend so a lot of
women get mad at me because I put it on
the women but if we're leaving and
taking the children how can we be mad
and say oh it's the lack of male role
models well if it weren't for your
choices Diane there wouldn't be a lack
of male role models but that that's not
even that's not the guy's fault they're
Vanishing because our culture is
devaluing traditional masculine virtues
and skills so basically because the
world lacks more guys like Andrew Tate
and Jordan Peterson and because
masculinity is now considered toxic I'll
discuss more in a moments anyways now
back to when you insult Men by putting
Ray Barone and Homer Simpson on
television 20 to 30 years ago did you
not see how many men wouldn't just walk
away from the marriage Plantation clown
world show given the choice between
being a doofus like Homer Simpson and
chilling out in your mother's basement
Like a Villain it's pretty clear you'll
check out yeah and the thing is that's
what the media is pushing that we need
women to lead relationships because men
are so incompetent
and then we get surprised when the men
are like nah I don't want to sign up for
this happy wife happy life that's not
really that doesn't sound great for me
because soy Sunny won't give you any
respect when you turn 60 of men under
the age of 30 in tin cells and on off
from a realistic chance of having kids
and a wife oh and I actually was
thinking like do women have a duty to
society that's a question do women have
a duty to society to pick someone on our
level and make children like do women
owe anything to society because the men
built the society right so the men came
through and as a group they built
Society even to this day they're in
charge of all the systems that make
Society run
um they even have given us more
Privileges and freedoms and some would
even say it's almost Supremacy over the
men that built the society so knowing
that do women owe anything to society
and what's worse a male in cell or oh a
a single mother who can't make a
relationship work what has bigger imp
implications what's worse now I'm not
going to point fingers but if I had to
if I had to you know you guys you guys
could draw the conclusion on your own
you know and they they say like oh that
I'm just pandering I hate women but it's
just like what I logically think about
this stuff what are the Men supposed to
do you know the the politicians have to
they gave us the right to vote and now
the politicians have to Pander to us
because we're the biggest swing voting
group the media has to Pander to us
because we make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions the legal
system panders to us because of the way
the divorce laws are and the alimony is
so therefore the husbands have to Pander
to the wife so she won't leave and take
the kids and and so it just begs the
question you know men gave us the right
to vote because they thought it was the
right thing to do but then women get the
power and what do we do with it is
society in a better place now some of
the stand for nothing reaction channels
are going to say yes it is you get to do
this you get to do this and you know on
an individual level I can say sure
there's a lot of individual things make
the world you know for a woman a better
like happier place but the question is
what outcomes do we want for a society
do you really think that they'll keep
working for no cooch now the so-called
invisible men are making currency
invisible too because they're checking
out and creating inflation because there
aren't enough men to do the jobs that
are needed why would a young man today
take responsibility when he has no
authority over a wife or girlfriend and
has no way of buying a house and getting
ahead in life right so that's like what
are the incentive structures and then
we're gonna get mad at men for
being enough and then they act like like
I'm saying this to Pander but I just
like what I logically think about it
even though I'm a woman so I can't think
logically only emotionally
um although I do my best
um I can't really blame them tell men
they're toxic enough and tell women that
they're the bestest ever and women will
do just fine but men will have horrible
self-esteem and walk away from work in
The Mating Game entirely but again it's
not that the men are Vanishing many of
us are just taking a break from this
game until the rules change a little bit
so we have a fighting chance that
doesn't and that's the Mis misunderstood
thing about mgtow is it's not that they
hate women they are just walking away
it's like they're okay I don't know if
this is going to be a good comparison or
not when they wanted the segregation
laws do you remember in like the 60s or
whatever and Rosa Parks like Refuge they
refused to use the buses right um and so
they walked away from the buses and said
we're not going to use the buses until
you change these laws it wasn't seen as
oh you hate bus drivers it wasn't seen
as oh you you hate white people it was
seen as this is an unfair law and we're
walking away and boycotting this until
you change it and that's what the men
are doing with women
um they're walking away from women and
boycotting relationships until they have
the until the laws change
um and and that's why it just bothers me
when they just try to demonize these
guys because when you think about it I
understand I'm not saying every guy
should do it you have to decide that for
yourself but I get where they're coming
from include me though men going their
own way from work and women is having a
serious effect helping to fuel inflation
and when the system finally really
realizes that if you mistreat men we
walk away and civilization crumbles then
they'll reward us again but how do they
do that with such piss poor quality
women these days it's only going to get
worse as the sex spots roll out and with
all the high quality virtual sex that
you can get on tap it'll be even harder
for guys to motivate themselves then
you'll have runaway inflation regardless
of the Federal Reserve interest rate
policy they used to be able to lead men
around with the carrot stick of sex
dangling in front of them but what
happens when technology gives that man a
carrot and he stops walking forward oh
that's really true it's going to drag
down civilization Elizabeth says that we
can no longer rely on people saying that
American men that work hard support
families and contribute to their
communities are Good Men We Now call
them toxic so now men prefer point to
relationships and dependence on their
parents in the state instead of
self-reliance men have given up and
don't care about helping a society that
marginalizes them plus let's not forget
that American men have no reason to work
towards greater comfort in life because
they're already comfortable living with
their parents so American men are
increasingly becoming like Southern
European men and who are they living
with their parents or their mothers be
honest the dad will kick you out of the
house the moms are the one letting the
kids stay you see it's like maybe I'm
wrong you could let me know if the guys
you know that stay with their parents
the ones I know it's typically their
moms not their dads unless they're like
the dads will let them stay if they're
contributing something that's that's
London's a bit different though people
do stay with their parents a little bit
longer here can you blame them that's
that's where I'm Elizabeth says this has
to be reversed but then as a mother of
three sons her husband and her are
committed to figuring the sounds so I
guess she cares thinking that her sons
are going to be living with her into
their middle age and she probably
doesn't like that so it's impacting her
personally and she doesn't want it to
it's like the people that give me for
not getting married and having a family
the way they have they worry the
population isn't replacing itself and
then not all men are doing their parts
but why reproduce when you get
disrespected for it and her label able
to be food for getting married by
mainstream culture also a few of us
choosing to reproduce isn't going to
change the tide of population crash wait
and see what happens in 10 years time
with lumberbots and AI girlfriends guys
will have almost no incentive to
reproduce anymore the 1.5 or 1.6
fertility rate today is going to look
high compared to the levels below 1 in
10 years in most Western countries we
won't even be halfway how scary is that
like what if a population rate dropped
below one yeah because right now it's
like 1.5 or something for the number of
like kids being born but he's saying
when AI gets like brought in it's going
to drop below one because not aim like
the robots like when they get more
realistic like factual stuff that
they're then going to
yeah reproducing ourselves in each
generation will be 60 smaller than the
last one then men and women won't just
be invisible but will be non-existent
this is inevitable at this point people
are going to be shocked at how fast
Global populations crash all these
trivial Tales of men failing to launch
will be pushed aside as men become even
more apathetic towards the future men
have lost hope this is one of the
reasons why culture is so important why
we need Innovative films music and shows
to inspire the young Holly woke in the
music business have been creatively
bankrupt for a decade now where the new
Innovative sci-fi shows other than the
expanse to illustrate a hopeful future I
haven't seen any lately it's just
remakes and repurposed content if I'm
not hopeful about the future then all I
have is the comfortable presence love
them or hate him Elon Musk as at least
inspired people with his Rockets growing
up many of us had Star Trek to inspire
us to become engineers a rather awesome
film and television shows to inspire us
to get into media production like myself
the world lacks Beauty and purpose to
get guys off their couch in addition to
the possibility of having sex Elizabeth
is going to have to watch her sons get
addicted to adult fapping off material
and fail to launch where it's going to
get really interesting is if sex spots
are developed how are teen guys supposed
to sneak one into the house if it can't
walk on in its own and has limited
Mobility then again it might become
socially acceptable and mothers will
have to give in eventually I don't think
so without a fight but I can definitely
smell a holly woke movie covering it at
some point then again they probably will
because it'll be interpreted as misogyny
or something buckle up for the ride guys
the world is about to look more like the
film's children and men in the future
rather than Star Trek maybe that's why
the so-called time traveler that was on
Coast to Coast radio said that in the
distant future people would be forced to
have children and contribute to society
or they'd be kicked off the Giant
floating cities that were controlled by
Ai and put in the wilderness where they
there's a time traveler have to be
self-reliance since they'd be so
dependent on the technocratic state they
were living in for most their lives that
would mean almost certain death but
enough of my ramblings and yet another
experimental type of video anyways
that's it for today I want to see the
time traveler I want to see wait no pull
up the next one all right you know what
I'll make that apart too I'll make it a
part two so guys we're gonna release
another video reacting to the time
travelers to see if any of this doomsy
stuff is coming
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments though I really understand
mgtow I think when you really like take
a look at the systems in place you
understand where they're coming from
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time